fast 40 jahre lang legten china und die
usa eine partnerschaft
wandel durch handel war die hoffnung und
wohl auch die illusion
die ist einer bitteren realität gewichen
in unzähligen propagandavideos
inszeniert china seine neue militär
stärke
die weltmacht amerika soll verstehen
peking fordert sie heraus
fast täglich testet chinas führung wie
weit sie rote linien verschieben können
er füllt sich präsident lee sein traum
taiwan heim ins reich zu holen
[Musik]
china stellt die machtfrage an den
rivalen
amerika
[Musik]
amerika rüstet sich für einen
militärischen schotter
präsident biden erklärt die rivalität
zur schicksalsfrage für die menschheit
zum kampf zwischen demokratie und
diktatur die usa investieren milliarden
um ihre technologie vor chinas einfluss
zu schützen und werben bei regierungen
weltweit für die freiheit amerika fühlt
sich berufen china zu stoppen angeblich
um einmal mehr die welt zu retten
in zwei weltkriegen haben amerikaner
dafür gesorgt dass ihre flagge zum
symbol für freiheit und menschenrechte
wurde
werte die auf amerikanischem boden einst
blutig erkämpft wurden aber
nationalstolz und pathos verleihen dem
land nur einen anschein von einigkeit
wer die führungsmacht der welt zeigt
schwächen
die menschen streiten wer die wahren
patrioten sind jene die das land
verändern wollen um es gerechter
vielfältiger und damit stärker zu machen
oder jene die möglichst wenig
veränderungen wollen und mit dem
autoritär ismus liebäugeln
[Musik]
so sieht er aus der amerikanische traum
dass jeder es schaffen kann wenn man nur
hart genug dafür arbeitet sind in
portland einem kleinen ort im
us-bundesstaat ohio an diesem
strahlenden herbstmorgen wartet messer
bush auf ihren achtjährigen sohn max
es ist eine szene wie sie sich überall
in amerika am spiel was nach heiler welt
aussieht war keine
selbstverständlichkeit für die kleine
familie
denn noch vor der geburt von nächsten
hatte david busch gelernte elektriker
seinen job verloren der autokonzern
general motors machte damals ein großes
werk in der nähe dich zulieferbetriebe
gingen pleite david fand nur arbeit auf
zeit hunderte meilen entfernt in anderen
bundesstaaten
es war extrem hart wir mussten viele
opfer bringen waren viel getrennt
so viele monate in denen ich ihn nur
einmal oder auch nur jeden zweiten monat
gesehen habe und dann auch nur ein zwei
tage das war's
der amerikanische traum ist für mich
sind meine frau und mein sohn glücklich
sind gesund wenn wir nicht vom einen
gehaltsscheck zum nächsten leben müssen
mit der ständigen angst im nacken dass
ich meine rechnungen nicht bezahlen kann
wenn ich arbeitslos werde
mein eigenes haus zu besitzen einen
eigenen platz auf dem planeten wo
niemand mehr sagen kann was ich tun soll
und die möglichkeit für meinen sohn es
besser zu haben als ich
dieser traum platzte damals für viele
die gegend war einst eine hochburg der
stahl- und autoindustrie jetzt zeugen
die ruinen von dieser besseren zeit die
schuld an all dem gaben die menschen der
gewinn hier der unternehmen den
billigsten löhnen in asien ganz
besonders in china und der politik die
zu liest dass amerikas industriebasis
verrottete
aber jetzt tut sich wieder was wir sind
auf dem dach eines unternehmens das auf
sonnenenergie umstellt david leitet die
installation der solar panelen nach
einer weiterbildung hat er wieder eine
dauerhafte stelle in einer
zukunftsbranche die regierung will den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien in den
kommenden jahren massiv fördern und
david hofft dass die technologien dafür
wieder mehr in den usa produziert werden
es ist traurig wir waren einst ein
großes industrieland wir alles
produziert haben dass wir wollen jetzt
sind wir und übersee china asien und all
diese länder angewiesen für alles was
wir brauchen all unserer ressourcen
bevor deren fortschritt dabei sollten
sie doch unseren fortschritt antreiben
viele amerikaner sehen in china ein
kommunistisches regime das die welt
dominieren den wirtschaftlich
militärisch politisch das wollten die
usa zwar auch immer aber sie sehen sich
als verteidiger demokratischer werte
beim chinesisch amerikanischen gipfel im
märz 2021 setzte washington die menschen
und bürgerrechte verletzungen an den
muslimischen uiguren in der provinz
xinjiang und der protestbewegung in
hongkong auf die tagesordnung
wir werden unsere tiefsten sorgen chinas
verhalten diskutieren in bezug auf china
hongkong taiwan cyber angriffe auf die
usa und die wirtschaftliche erpressung
unserer verbündeten all das bedroht die
regelbasierte ordnung die die globale
stabilität ein
die luft im saal brannte mit moralischen
überlegenheit denken und kraftstrotzende
imponiergehabe
lassen sie mich für die chinesische
seite sagen die vereinigten staaten sind
nicht qualifiziert mit china aus einer
position der stärke heraus zu sprechen
die usa waren auch in den letzten 20 30
jahren nicht qualifiziert so etwas zu
sagen weil es keine art ist mit dem
chinesischen volk umzugehen
das hier meinte chinas wichtigster
außenpolitiker bilder an der grenze
zwischen den usa und mexiko
das harte vorgehen der amerikanischen
behörden
menschenrechtsverletzungen behauptet
und dann auch das hier aufständische die
das parlament stürmen die demokratie ins
wanken bringen von einer regierung die
den frieden im eigenen land nicht
garantieren kann will peking sich nichts
sagen lassen joe biden hat mühe die
trümmer aus tramm tagen zu beseitigen
erfordert von den verbündeten china die
stirn zu bieten
menschenrechte seien wichtiger als gute
geschäfte aber so eine moralische
außenpolitik können sich die usa
eigentlich gar nicht leisten weil auch
sie abhängig sind vom handel mit dem
privat
das zeigen auch tausende von leeren
containern im frachthafen von long beach
kalifornien die usa importierten 2020
waren im wert von 435 milliarden dollar
aus china
exportierten doch den aber nur güter im
wert von 125 milliarden für die benötigt
man entsprechend weniger content us
firmen investierten 124 milliarden
dollar in china dreimal mehr als
umgekehrt weil die amerikaner wichtige
schlüsseltechnologien für ihre hightech
geräte brauchen halbleiter mikrochips
batterien werden zwar auch in taiwan und
südkorea hergestellt vor allem aber in
china aus dieser abhängigkeit will sich
amerika jetzt befreit
die lieferketten von allen sind sehr eng
mit taiwan und china verzahnt wenn es
also irgendeine geopolitische krise gäbe
hoffentlich natürlich nicht dann muss
jeder darauf vorbereitet sein deshalb
reden wir jetzt über eine
diversifizierung die uns vor allen
problemen schützen soll die in einer
region entstehen in der die
produktionsstätten ziemlich konzentriert
klingt logisch aber was über jahre
versäumt wurde weil man sich auf die
produktion in asien verließ lässt sich
nicht so schnell nachholen
also werden den phoenix arizona
millionen von kubikmetern sand bedeckt
es entstehen brandneue
produktionsstätten für halbleiter und
mikrochips allein hier investiert intel
20 milliarden dollar noch einmal 20 für
ein weiteres werk in ohio es ist eine
wirtschaftliche und politische
kampfansage an china auf druck der us
regierung baut in arizona auch der
halbleiterproduzent tsmc aus taiwan für
12 milliarden dollar im benachbarten
texas der südkoreanische samsung-konzern
für 17 milliarden
das ist amerikas einzige quelle für
einen der wichtigsten rohstoffe der
zukunft in silver peak nevada wird unter
hochdruck lithium aus den felsen
ausgespült unverzichtbares metall für
die herstellung von batterien
china verfügt als einziges land über die
komplette herstellungskette von den
rohstoffen bis zur fertigen batterie 80
prozent der weltproduktion kommen aus
china
diese vormachtstellung will amerika
brechen die lithium förderung wird
vervierfacht es ist auch eine frage der
nationalen sicherheit
eine militärische eskalation würde wohl
nicht nur die lithium produktion treffen
sondern die gesamte lieferkette man sie
derzeit sehr von der produktion in asien
abhängig ist aber in zukunft wird sich
das risiko verteilen wenn die
lieferketten lokale organisiert sind und
mehr batteriekomponenten für
elektroautos außerhalb von asien
hergestellt werden
hier entsteht für mehr als zwei
milliarden dollar eine batteriefabrik
als home sales ist teil des versuchs wie
china die komplette herstellungskette im
eigenen land zu haben und amerikas
autoproduktion auf elektrofahrzeuge
umzustellen wir wollen herausfinden ob
die hoffnung auf ein comeback der
industrie wirklich wieder da ist in rast
einer unweit der fabriken in der krise
kamen nur noch wenige jetzt treffen wir
bauarbeiter tischler elektriker
elektroautos was neues aber gut
den steigenden benzinpreisen jetzt wenn
ich total dafür es wird viel billiger
als mit einem benzinauto ich würde auch
gern ein elektroauto frauen worden nicht
jeder neue firmenname hier klingt wie
dieser nach weltkonzern aber die technik
dahinter soll weltweit führend sein um
china auf distanz zu halten sie
versuchen ein imperium zu schaffen sowie
unseres das ist die menschliche natur
jeder will so viel habe nämlich mit
amerikanischem einfallsreichen so lange
wie effizient und effektiv sind werden
wir weiter wachsen dann bleiben wir für
immer die nummer eins
[Musik]
amerika die nummer 1 bleibt entscheidet
sich auch hier
taiwans streitkräfte üben für den
ernstfall
die waffen kommen vor allem aus den usa
denn sie brauchen taiwans
wirtschaftskraft und tsmc den
drittgrößten halbleiterhersteller der
welt die taiwanesische präsident hinweis
dass genau deshalb ihre insel zum
schlachtfeld werden könnte denn china
droht immer unverhohlener
mit dem einmarsch
[Musik]
wir sprechen mit dem außenminister
joseph hrubesch wird den kampf in der
taiwanese aber fordert auch militärische
unterstützung wenn china taiwan angreift
denn dann steht die zukunft der gesamten
freien welt mit auf dem spiel vor die
marcus thies
demokratien sollten die lage sehr
nüchtern betrachten und darüber
nachdenken ob wir dem autoritarismus
erlauben unser leben zu dominieren
wenn wir das nicht wollen müssen wir
china unmissverständlich klar machen
dass die demokratien chinas bösartigen
einfluss auf andere länder nicht
tolerieren
dem mord demokratien sollten
zusammenstehen um den autoritarismus
davon abzuschrecken wie sich weiter
auszubreiten
seit mehr als 100 jahren ist es
erklärtes ziel der vereinigten staaten
für demokratie und freiheit zu kämpfen
joe biden weiß genau das amerikanische
militär interventionen oft auch nur
einen machtinteressen dienten manchmal
menschenrechte auf der strecke blieb
und diesmal will die us-regierung vor
allem die lebensadern der weltwirtschaft
die handelswege im indopazifik
chinesischer willkür schützen
aber für amerikas politiker ist die
rivalität mit china so wie damals auch
ein kampf gegen autoritär ismus und
diktatur
in bezug auf taiwan gibt es die einsicht
dass unser einfluss in der zukunft
schmilzt wenn wir gegenüber china nicht
für unsere partner und verbündeten
einstehen und wege finden dagegen zu
halten nicht unbedingt konfrontativ aber
entschieden
außenminister bube feiert die sogenannte
strategische vieldeutigkeit peking soll
nicht wissen ob washington eingreifen
würde oder nicht
wir sind sehr zuversichtlich dass die
zusagen der vereinigten staaten
felsenfest sind daran zweifeln wir nicht
wirklich abschrecken lässt china sich
wohl nicht soldaten der
volksbefreiungsarmee
üben eine invasion solche
kriegsszenarien im indopazifik spielte
das
us-verteidigungsministerium im herz 2020
einfach mal durch die simulationen
ließen alle alarmglocken schrillen immer
wieder siegte china seitdem überarbeitet
das pentagon mit hochdruck die
stationierung szene in der region und
feilt an neuen taktiken für mögliche
waffen ging es ist nicht
notwendigerweise realistisch dass wir
verlieren werden aber die
geschwindigkeit der militärischen
entwicklung chinas macht es jetzt
schwieriger für uns eindeutig zu
gewinnen
noch sind die usa die größte
militärmacht der welt der etat ist fast
dreimal so groß wie der chinesische
dafür ist chinas marine mittlerweile mit
350 schiffen die größte der welt mit
fast so viele nur boten wie den usa
wobei flugzeugträgern hat amerika einen
deutlichen vorsprung und ist damit fähig
militärische macht rund um den erdball
einzusetzen
michael you macht sich einen kleinen
imbiss um sich dann gestärkt in die
schlacht zu stürzen der informatiker
simuliert in seiner wohnung im
kanadischen vancouver kriegsszenarien im
indopazifik und stellt sie auf youtube
er will der öffentlichkeit erklären wie
schnell die lage eskalieren kann er hat
quellen im militär und recherchiert
penibel die taktiken und waffensysteme
der rivale
michael zeigt uns eine simulation mit
einem realen ausgangspunkt fast jede
woche dringend chinesische
kampfflugzeuge in den luftraum um taiwan
ein
ständige provokationen manchmal 20 30
jets und bomber gleichzeitig
in dieser zusammensetzung könnten sie
amerikanische flottenverbände nahe
taiwan überraschend angreifen
es käme zunächst zum luftkampf beide
seiten hätten wohl heftige verluste
dann aber würde china landgestützten
raketen einsätzen über die es erst seit
wenigen jahren verfügt
immer wieder in michael simulationen
geschieht dasselbe wie bei den übungen
des pentagons die amerikanische marine
verliert das gefecht der flugzeugträger
und ein teil der begleitschiffe
ausgeschaltet die bahn frei für den
einmarsch in taiwan
ich hoffe sehr dass es nicht ein heißer
krieg wird ein echter konflikt aber ich
halte das für möglich weil bei
wachsenden spannungen ein kleiner
zufälliger vorfall geschehen kann dann
weiter eskaliert
ein flottenverband komplett ausgelöscht
während amerika nach neuen strategien
und taktiken sucht verwandelt china im
südchinesischen meer unwirtliche mini
insel mit viel sand und zement im
militärstützpunkte eine bedrohung für
die handelswege
in china sieht sich selbst als die
führende macht dieser welt und zur mitte
des jahrhunderts werden sie diesen
anspruch nur schwer verwirklichen können
ohne taiwan zu erobern eine seite hat
eine gesamtstrategie nämlich china und
die vereinigten staaten handelt
fahrlässig keine übergreifende strategie
zu entwickeln
ohne diese werden wir versagen und china
wird uns bis zur mitte des jahrhunderts
überholen
deshalb müssten die usa für den
militärischen showdown im indopazifik
denn der nummer eins sein will braucht
taiwan und braucht freie handelswege
härtetest für amerikas neuesten
flugzeugträger im militärischen
wettrennen haben die usa noch die nase
vorn aber auf anderen feldern laufen sie
china hinterher
wir sind unterwegs im senegal wo die us
regierung versucht chinas
wirtschaftlichen einfluss in afrika zu
brechen mit milliarden-investitionen der
initiative bild bag better world
senegal braucht infrastruktur für seine
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hier draußen
gibt es keine asphaltstraßen mehr keine
verlässliche wasserversorgung zwei
stunden von der hauptstadt dhaka
entfernt auch keinen strom
mit einem 100 millionen dollar auftrag
soll ein us unternehmen das nun ändern
ortstermin bei einem chef di will als
bürgermeister
zu seinem ort gehören dutzende von
siedlungen er preist die kooperation
zwischen senegal und amerika
patrick henry und papa sei von der us
firma value amount sollen 50.000
holzmasten kabel und spannungs verteiler
aus den usa liefern und installieren
die amerikaner hören zu gehen auf die
bedürfnisse ein
der strom schafft chancen für kleine
betriebe für die kühle lagerung und
verarbeitung landwirtschaftlicher
erzeugnisse aber auch für die kinder in
der schule
will papa und pat zeigen wo überall
leitungen hin sollen damit möglichst
viele häuser strom bekommen
bei der fahrt werden uns die
herausforderungen klar wenn die
distanzen zur hauptleitung zu groß
werden erreicht das material des
projekts am ende nur für 300 siedlungen
nicht für 500
in ihrem auftreten unterscheiden sich
die amerikaner bewusst von chinesischen
firmen die oft vertragsbedingungen
diktieren und sogar arbeiter aus china
ein
manchmal beschäftigen wir die
dorfbewohner und die masten abzuladen
und in den löchern aufzurichten damit
das projekt auch dem dorf ein paar
einnahmen bringen
sympathien sammeln das ist teil der
us-strategie china im wettbewerb um
großaufträge in afrika auszustechen
die bevölkerung des kontinents ist jung
bis zum ende des jahrhunderts könnte
sich die zahl der menschen derzeit 1,4
milliarden verdreifacht
sie brauchen perspektiven
damit sich ihre träume von einem
besseren leben erfüllen china und die
usa ist es eine chance neue verbündete
zu finden denn die afrikanischen
regierungen wollen eine wiedergeburt
afrikas so heißt auch die statue
oberhalb von dakar
die partner können dabei gleichzeitig
gute geschäfte machen denn afrika ist
ein riesiger markt china hat das
schneller erkannt als die usa und europa
und 2020 schon waren im wert von 114
milliarden dollar nach afrika exportiert
fünfmal so viel wie die vereinigten
staaten
chinesische unternehmen bauen den
nahverkehr in der metropole dakar für
solche aufträge gibt die chinesische
staatsbank super günstige kredite mit
laufzeiten bis zu 30 jahren peking
erwartet als gegenleistung auch zugriff
auf seltene rohstoffe und politischen
einfluss
genau deshalb bemühen sich die usa jetzt
gegenzuhalten die amerikanische ex im
bank bietet ebenfalls günstige
kreditfinanzierungen an nur so konnte
weil die la mont die mittelständische
firma aus chicago
400 millionen dollar geschäft mit dem
senegal abschließen
ernst nenne ich mit china power
antwortet konkurriere eine firma die in
ganz westafrika tätig ist dann ist das
kein privatunternehmen es ist staatlich
ich konkurriere also mit der
chinesischen regierung die eximbank hat
mir geholfen nicht mit den gleichen
bedingungen die hier anbietet aber mit
wettbewerbsfähigen bedingungen
wir leben wie us aussenminister blinken
beim besuch in dakar bild berg where the
world als faire partnerschaft an preis
die die rechte der arbeiter und den
schutz der umwelt garantieren
unser ziel ist nicht unsere partner vor
die wahl zu stellen wir wollen ihnen
auswahlmöglichkeiten und wenn menschen
wählen können dann wählen sie für
gewöhnlich das richtige
wir haben eine diplomatie der
souveränität aus der wien jemanden
niemanden ausschließen und gleichzeitig
auch gesetzte freundin historische
partner
wir werfen die alten nicht für die neuen
weg wir arbeiten mit allen zusammen
nicht weit entfernt kommen nach einem
harten tag auf dem meer die fischer
zurück sie scheinen zufrieden mit ihrer
ausbeute
bilder aus einem land in
aufbruchstimmung
auch weil sich zwei supermächte hier und
den anderen teilen der welt mit
milliarden-investitionen
sympathien erkaufen wollen diesen
wettbewerb können die amerikaner kaum
gewinnen
weil die usa und ihre europäischen
verbündeten afrikas potenzial lange
nicht erkannt haben meint der ehemalige
bundestagsabgeordnete charles huber
jetzt berater des senegalesischen
präsidenten
man hat afrika entweder aus ignoranz
oder aus bequemlichkeit
unterschätzt und kinder hat es nicht
getan um den wettbewerb auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent mit dem wir es
ja mittlerweile zu tun haben den hat
china in die wege geleitet und das
würden die afrikanischen ländern
china immer hoch anrechnen
am mächtigen mississippi legt maske team
in dieser kleinstadt findet man spuren
einer zeit in der amerika einst für
china das tat was china seit einigen
jahren für afrika tut in den 80er jahren
als die kommunistische führung in peking
das land für westliche einflüsse öffnete
als die usa die wirtschaftsbeziehungen
massiv ankurbelten kam ein junger
chinese hierher weil er amerika
bewundert
hier nahmen ihn gasteltern auf
mittlerweile ist es ein museum sino
amerikanisches freundschafts haus nennt
es herr glatt
der chinesische milliardär und
eigentümer des hauses zeigt uns die
fotos von dem gast
damals vor fast 40 jahren war ich in
ping als junge parteifunktionär hier um
sich neueste entwicklungen in der
landwirtschaft anzuschauen und um den
american way of life kennen zu lernen
die kleine delegation hatte
offensichtlich eine gute zeit
zeigt uns das zimmer dass ich hier und
ein freund
er mochte den lebensstil sehr
damals fehlte es in china an
nahrungsmittel an allen möglichen waren
da draußen sah er die kinder die mit
autos zur schule gebracht wurden und so
ein gutes leben hatten
hier kam 2012 als vizepräsident noch
einmal zurück nach muscat ihm die
bekanntschaften von einst haben lange
geheim wir wollen wissen wie herr glatt
darüber denkt was hier jetzt antreibt
seine antwort fällt vorsichtig aus der
nächst geschäftsmann pendelt zwischen
den usa und china
er will dass die chinesen das gleiche
leben haben wie die andere
dass sie eine gute umwelt und den
frieden genießen können
was er für china getan hat tat er aus
guter absicht für das chinesische volk
aber all das politische jetzt wir wissen
nicht warum das so ist
die rivalen sehen sich offenbar als
gegenseitige bedrohung dabei gebe es
gemeinsame interessen wie den kampf
gegen den klimawandel bei denen sie
zusammenarbeiten müssten tun sie es
nicht verlieren bayer das und die immer
noch engen wirtschaftsbeziehungen
könnten den showdown um die
vormachtstellung zumindest hinauszögern
das ist die herausforderung des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts wir
wollen einen krieg vermeiden das
verhältnis mit china bieten es aber auf
keinen fall zerbrechen und dann in einem
krieg lang
wir sind zurück in ohio wo die menschen
amerikas angst vor dem abstieg in ihrem
leben erfahren
an einen möglichen krieg mit china wagt
niemand denken zumal es gerade erst
wieder aufwärts geht die konflikte in
den usa selbst scheinen viel
gefährlicher für stabilität und
wohlstand joe biden muss erst mal dafür
sorgen dass die demokratie neue
perspektiven bietet für familien wie die
von mess- und david busch ihr traum
unterscheidet sich nicht von dem was
wohl auch viele chinesen fern von den
muskelspielen ihres anführers sich für
ihre kinder wünschen und muss hoffen
dass nächsten erstmal besser hat als
seine eltern
dass er endlose chancen hat seinen
lebensweg auszuwählen voranzukommen
etwas beizutragen für die welt egal wie
groß oder klein
das ist der amerikanische traum wo damit
nichts anfangen könntest und sich deine
träume am ende doch erfüllen das ist
harter aber sondern nicht viele sind
noch bereit dazu wir müssen dahin
zurückkommen wenn wir das nicht schaffen
dann könnte der amerikanische traum
verschwinden
dieser traum gehört zum gründungsmythos
der vereinigten staaten aber er hat
risse bekommen
die nation hat angst vor dem abstieg und
joe biden nur wenig zeit um seinem land
wieder hoffnung geblieben
joe biden muss zuallererst die
amerikanische demokratie bewahren nur
wenn die menschen wieder an ihrer
eigenen stärken glauben kann amerika das
symbol für fortschritt bleiben und china
als rivalen auf abstand halten
china will die vorherrschaft es geht
dabei nicht nur um marktanteile
es geht dabei auch um unsere art zu
leben eine welt nach der vorstellung der
kommunistischen partei ist eine welt
ohne freiheit wie wir sie verstehen
wie wirkt sich keegan pings kontroll
staat auf die freiheit der bürger aus
was hat all das mit unserer freiheit zu
tun
wie sieht chinas neuer nationalismus aus
und wie wirkt sich das auf den einstigen
partner usa aus
das seht ihr in unserem ersten teil von
die rivalen china